Welcome back.
I scared you, I'm sure.
I have more energy.
I'm actually fasting
today, but I won't
go into it too much.
I don't want to go too much into
my personal life, but I
eat one meal a day now and
I have so much energy.
It's unbelievable.
Hope you don't think I'm crazy,
but it's back to the
SAT videos.
So let's see, we're on
problem number 15.
So I drew it out ahead of time,
because I didn't want to
waste your time because
it's more valuable
than mine, I think.
Considering I have so much time
now that I only eat one
meal a day.
They say, in the figure above,
triangle PQR is equilateral
and SR and TV intersect
at point P.
What is the value of y?
So let's just use all the
information they give us.
This is an equilateral
triangle.
So what do you know about
equilateral triangles?
All the angles in
an equilateral
triangle are the same.
This is going to be 60 degrees,
this going to be 60
degrees, and this whole
thing is going to
be 60 degrees, right?
Well, if this whole thing is
60 degrees, then what's x?
Well, there's three x's,
and they're equally
splitting it, right?
So this is 20 degrees, this is
20 degrees and this is 20
degrees, right?
Well, what's equal to angle y?
From our geometry module, we
know that angle y is equal to
the opposite angle, right?
Angle y is going to be equal
to-- so you got to pay close
attention to which
lines this is.
So that line and that
line, right?
So the opposite angle
to angle y is this
angle right here, right?
So that angle is just two of the
three x's, so it's 20 and
20, so angle y is equal
to 40 degrees.
It just equals two of
these x degrees.
That's it.
All right, number 16.
Maybe I could do it here with
this kind of toothpaste
colored ink.
Let the operations triangle and
square be defined for all
real numbers a and b as follows,
a-- I like these
problems-- a triangle b
is equal to a plus 3b.
And then a square b is
equal to a plus 4b.
And then they have this thing.
If 4 triangle of 5y is equal
to 5y square 4, what is the
value of y?
Well this might seem bizarre
to you, but we just have to
map these functions to-- And
this is just functions in
disguise, right?
A function of two variables.
Let's see, so what
is 4 triangle 5y?
So let's go to the triangle
function.
That's this one, right?
So in this case,
a is 4, right?
Because it's the number before
the triangle, so that's equal
to 4 plus 3 times b.
Well, what's b?
b is whatever's after
the triangle, right?
In this case it's 5y.
So 3 times b would
be 3 times 5y.
Let me do some coloring here.
This is just this, right?
And then if I do the other side
of that-- 5y square 4.
So in this case, 5-- so we're
using the square.
So in this case 5y
is a, right?
So that equals 5y plus 4b.
And what's b?
Well, b is whatever's after
the rectangle, right?
So 4b is 4 times 4.
And now we just solve.
So let's see.
4 times-- 4 plus-- let me just
rewrite that-- 4 plus 3 times
5 is 15y is equal
to 5y plus 16.
Let's take 4 from both
sides, so you get 15y
equals 5y plus 12.
Take 5y from both sides, you
get 10y is equal to 12.
y is equal to 12/10, and then
we can reduce that.
Divide the top to bottom by 2,
so y is equal to 6/5, and that
is our answer.
These are these kind of fill in
the blank ones, so you can
actually write that--
bubble it in.
The SAT wasn't like that
I when I took it.
Actually, these problems
are really good.
Let's move on.
Number 17.
Let me switch to magenta,
bright magenta.
In the xy-coordinate plane, the
graph of x is equal to y
squared minus 4 intersects the
line l, at 0 comma p, and the
point 5 comma t, right?
These are two points
on the line l.
What is the greatest possible
value of the slope of l?
So this is interesting.
So x is equal to y
squared minus 4.
So, first of all, you need
realize this isn't how you
normally write a function,
right?
You normally write it y is
equal to x something.
But, what this is going to look
like-- x plus 4 is equal
to y squared-- And you don't
have to draw this actually on
the SAT test. It's going to
take you too much time.
But I think it's useful here
to have a visualization of
this, right?
So the graph is going to look
something like this.
It's going to actually
start at minus 4.
It's going to look something
like this,
the graph-- oh, woops.
I'm still using the line tool.
The graph is going to look
something like this.
Start back here at minus 4.
I think.
And then the line l-- we can
only assume since it
intersects it at two points,
it's going to look something
like this, right?
Where this could be 0 comma
p, and this is 5 comma t.
What's important to realize is
that both of these points
satisfy this relationship,
right?
Because they're on this curve.
So we can do that with
our math, right?
We could write this as
0 comma-- Well, if x
is 0, what is y?
Well, 0 is equal to
y squared minus 4.
We add 4 to both sides.
Y squared is equal to 4.
So y is equal to plus
or minus 2.
And that's the tricky part,
right? y is equal to
plus or minus 2.
And then what does this equal?
If x is equal to 5, what is t?
What could this term
right here be?
So let's see, 5 is equal
to y squared minus 4.
y squared is equal to 9.
y is equal to plus or minus 3.
Fascinating.
Actually I drew this
original graph.
Since it's written this way,
since it's not written as a
square root, it actually
would kind of do
something like this.
You don't have to draw this.
So anyway.
Plus or minus 3.
So these are the possible
two points we could have
intersected.
And what the question is
asking is, what is the
greatest possible value
of the slope of l?
What we want to figure out--
If we want the greatest
possible value, we want to go
from a very low number to a
very high number, right?
The x values are fixed.
We want as great a possible
change in y, given that change
in x, right?
So if we want the lowest
possible value here, we'll go
with the negative 2.
If we want the highest
possible value of x,
we'll go with 3.
So let's see.
So if we assume that, the
change in y is 3 minus
negative 2 over change
in x, 5 minus 0.
Adds up, right?
So this is 3 plus
2 is 5 over 5.
It equals 1.
That is the greatest
possible slope.
I'll see you in the
next video.